now it's your turn to build the
temperature unit setting this will bring
together a lot of the concepts that you
learned and will take some time to
implement but we think you're ready for
it modify the app so that the right
temperature units are displayed to the
user use the assumption that we're
syncing metric data from the server
eventually we'll have a database on the
device and we don't want a mix of
fahrenheit and celsius data in there
hence we'll stay consistent by getting
metric data from the server and then
we'll convert on the fly to the
preferred units when we update the ui
after you make these changes i'll show
you what it looks like on the device
if you go to settings you'll see the
temperature unit's preference
if you tap on that you see a dialog with
two options
if you switch to imperial and then you
go back to the forecast list then you
see that all the temperatures now are in
fahrenheit
once it works answer this question which
subclass of preference did you use